pues son versiones encontradas por un
lado Rusia dice que este drone no estaba
identificado no se Estaba reportando
cuando Pues le fue pedido que se
reportara y que se acercaba además a la
Península de crimea recordemos esta
península en el 2014 Pues en Rusia se
apoderó de esta de este territorio que
antes era ucraniano y que sigue en
disputa Y entonces ese es uno de los
argumentos rusos por un lado que este
dron no se Estaba reportando y que Rusia
además Argumenta también que no fue en
ningún momento un avión ruso un jet ruso
el que allá chocado la hélice de este
drone que terminó derribándolo sino que
simplemente el dron según los rusos
estaba siendo maniobras bastante
arriesgadas y terminó chocándose con el
mar Negro por su parte Estados Unidos lo
que Argumenta Es que esto no se trata de
ningún accidente y no se trata de ningún
accidente dice Washington porque antes
precisamente de que supuestamente un jet
ru so chocara la hélice de este drone
pues en varias ocasiones dice el
pentágono se le arrojó gasolina a este
drone y se trató de provocar se trató de
hacer maniobras bastante arriesgadas en
el vuelo que llevaba a cabo este drone y
después dice Washington pues chocó el el
la hélice de este drone que terminó
entonces derivado en el mar Negro
versiones encontradas pero ya hay
encuentro ya hay comunicación y las dos
partes quieren mantener ese canal de
comunicación abierta